so I would like first to thank you for
coming and I would also like to thank
Simon for accepting our invitation and
my colleagues for accepting for so when
I bought this book I was so impressed
that I decided to contact Simon and ask
him to come for a discussion and I think
that it is really possible to have a
conversation which is people are eating
each other
Simon is supposedly the literary scholar
when his book goes beyond literacy and I
would like to say why by introducing
interest okay Simon shikhandi is the
robber former professor of English at
Winston University and the editor of
poppy maybe he was born in Kenya and
this is very important to keep in mind
because I think that his scholarship
reflects what free tradition has been
trained in he graduated in literature
from the University of Nairobi he was a
british council scholar at the
University of Edinburgh Scotland from
which he graduated
in unison and he got his PhD from in
English from Auburn University
each tradition the Kenyan African
British and the American is actually
explored and confronted with the two
offers in Simon scholarship for Africa I
would like to mention his book an
article on Shinawatra being movie watch
one more book google watch on google a
choice outstanding academic publication
he's also become offer the Columbia
guide to East African literature in
English since 1935 he is the co-editor
of the Cambridge history of African and
Caribbean literature and the editor of
the route ledge unscrew via of African
literature writing in a limo modernism
and Caribbean literature maps of
Englishness writing identity in the
culture of Colonials and his latest book
slavery and because of case could be
located at intersection goes overlap in
territory of anti-british and the
various Atlantic's he's made a field of
research and teaching our young girl for
literature's and culture of Africa India
the Caribbean and post-colonial region
the black Atlantic and the African
Diaspora he's also interested in the
encounter between Europe and in African
languages in the modern field of
literature and human rights and writing
and cultural policies
Simon is currently working on a book
called this thing called in
we colonize and their books and
modernism and 30 possible he has back
and he is editing the volume is open of
the Oxford history proper novel in
English but nobody nastika and we are
very excited to her from Simon and from
both free commentators we selected salia
Hoffman
Carol Smith Rosenberg and Mad Men go we
have selected the free colleague because
of their famous expertise in the field
of slavery Atlantic studies black
Atlantic studies and the 18th century
studies and their exploration of race
racialized identity civility property
the ages of slavery and democracy but
challenges slavery poses to freedom
sameness and difference aesthetic reason
and religion each of them bring the
unique perspective in the reading of
science war so let me present first
Sadia will be put first mentally she has
worked extensively on the issue of
slavery and enslavement from the US
African and British personality sagas
exploration of how slavery and we have
two lightest slavery has have
established a measure of man and ranking
of life compare quite nicely with simon
examination of slavery and be culture
taste has the two phases phases modern
they are both interested in the archives
and memories of slavery high culture
history and we can a logical
continuation because
structures and were disciplinary
constrained
immunization in Westham your slave on
the issue of memory
Simon quotes in his book the following
line from the wonderful book published
by sorrier news yo mama what is it we
choose to remember about nice is it will
Matlin Dobby has walked on the ambiguous
location of the French Caribbean island
that have played a transformative role
on France economy and material culture
while remaining culturally invisible it
is precisely what displacement and
metaphorical presence and representation
of slavery in the French cultural
repertoire in the attention to examining
her book Trading Places formulas and
culture in all the way she writes I am
very much interested by how the French
Empire perspective compared with you
know which Matlin identifies with the
mechanism of avoidance and absolute
representation of slavery compared with
the physical connection between matters
of our and taste and the political
economy of slave with scientist
but he called the two phases of
modernity last but not least my
colleague and friend Karl Smith
Rosenberg she brings her expertise in
early American history I'm sure that
Carol will engage Simon on the issue of
an iPod here Simon
the analogy polarity and the production
and placement of difference and the
issue of slave we have the threshold the
latest book is violent umpire a birth
woman an American identity explored one
image has she call it to exclude and we
inability to a school and the complex
the complex interaction of us and that
characterizes the unsettled trajectory
of the emergence
and national identity and it's a certain
task of transaction and then security
and repeated production it will be very
interesting for us to be out but three
scholars interpret Simon who will the
context of their foreign field and war
what we'll do is to first begin this
evening by hearing from each of our
first sprawling dazzling encyclopedia
book that accomplishes nothing short of
transforming our understand given to
Germany by details and weighs North
Atlantic slavery this formative to the
culture of taste and the ideology of the
aesthetic while the economies discussion
of racing modernity is conversant with
the most recent works about the books of
slavery race and modernity along 18th
century and the problem of freedom of
the age of revolution slavery the
culture of Teague's these issues with
the particular focus on beauty
sensibility and politeness which she
argues developed in part as an attempt
to stabilize the potentially excessive
and disruptive aspart aspect of commerce
and to mask the aggressive and violent
character
the Atlantic slave trade and the
excessive Oklahoma slavery the text
details the intimacy of culture and
commerce in the 18th century and in so
doing dissing challenged the notion of
the aesthetic and leads us to consider
the aesthetics the aesthetic practices
engendered by commodity production and
fashioned by the commodity who speaks a
Central Africa to conduct analysis of
slavery needs that it engages with the
meaning of quote the realm of
sensuousness of the site in which the
black body was imprisoned but which also
produced a conduit for its liberation
but Gilmore s lays the climb or Mogens
attention to the terrible beauty
engendered by on posters screen the
aesthetic wrought by racial subjection
and acts and redresses the sensory
negation and dispossession of the
enslaved and I guess I want to say
what's so important about Simon's work
is the way it both attends to an
aesthetic that was engendered by the
repression of the violence of slavery
and one that was absolutely complemented
quieted the counter aesthetic of the
enslaved deformed and exceeded the norms
extensibility of European culture and
the plantations out and I have a
question related to economics later
slavery that helped her taste illumines
the counter discourse of the aesthetic
fashion by the enslaved in the context
of spatial and performative practices
which range attending the common ground
to slay song to ritual of performance
practice it conduct Proctor's a new
understanding of the culture taste by
detailing the intimacy of the aesthetic
with the production of human commodities
the culture of taste and his reading is
disfigured and inhabited but all that it
seeks to disavow with Haldia slavery the
bloody underside of Europe's riches and
the negation of black life but the self
fashioning of the European was defined
to the negation and dispossession
the black self than what possibility for
self-fashioning
existed for the enslaved this is one of
the sending questions of the tax how is
likely made of the space of negation as
he writes for those who were trapped in
the political and moral economy of
slavery the presentation of the self
through the work of art or an engagement
with culture as a weapon against
commodification had the capacity to
salvage the human identity of Africans
in their sights of repression and denial
the text raises a number of questions
central to black Atlantic studies and
slavery studies how did the Baathist
slavery coexist with the culture of
taste with what aesthetic pleasure
possible in the scene a car that was
slavery how did the culture of
enlightenment would value the integrity
and autonomy of the self strip Africans
of selfhood humanity and autonomy how
that Africans critically engaged the
culture of taste how did the performance
of sorrow and able there were country
itself and psychic bondage and in
answering these questions later in the
culture case provides a rich analysis of
the performance practices and self
fashioning of gates laid from John canoe
to Juba to sorrow song and the economies
account making a modernity is its people
linked with the making of blackness as
both a negation of sensibility and the
very condition of its production the
usually marginalize figure of the block
is placed center stage and here it's
important to note that as we see ahead
that we he's literally talking about
this kind of marginalized figures in
18th century painting and what does it
mean to kind of centralize those figures
not only to recover a narrative of
subjectivity but to think about
aesthetics that are producing the
portraits themselves another important
aspect of the taxes consideration of the
meaning
social death in the forms of life and
practice that unfold within his space
become his reading his nuance he
revisits and qualified the literature
lay resistance yet as scrupulous in
detailing the world's made under the
impossible munitions of enslavement as
important as the books thematic
attention to the ghost of slavery is so
as its method for conquering the ghosts
conduct allegorical motive reading
provides a means of avoiding
instrumental and crudely deterministic
readings of the relation between taste
and slavery by creating intersections
and constellations between distinct and
commensurable and antagonistic registers
experience the allegory of routing as
well reckons with the specter of slavery
in a present both in terms of our
scholarly blindness the categories of
the unthought which make it impossible
to think of the enslaved as political
actors and historical agents or which
make it impossible to think of European
modernity as they dependent upon
Atlantic slavery and as well that
highlights the racialized culture of
modernity which we still inhabit the
allegory of leading is suffused by the
Nama kolya the economy everywhere
detects the slave culture the allegory
of reading is a practice shade and now
that folio and here I mean that
melancholia is a critical method it is a
way of establishing relations between
past and present it is a way of
grappling with the irreparable violence
of slavery and the world is made in the
wake of this violence it is a practice
intent upon excavating forgotten
histories tracing the itinerary of the
disappearance and engaging a web of
memories which sport us with things for
God and with screaming presences the
incommensurability
and experience of slavery and the
epistemological categories of Western
eternity directs the economy's gaze not
to at the system illogical categories of
structure thought patterns of arguments
approves and certify standards of
explanation but to the constituent
outside of majority the black figure
lurking outside the discourse of unique
and who at the same time to find it
nowhere is the melancholic character of
the allegorical motorboat that are
Illustrated than in interceptions which
is chapter 2 of the text and
intersections narrate the lives of two
representative agents and through the
years
Anna Margaret of our pent and Neely by
contrasting a day to each woman's life
Monday April 24th 1797 which was a very
good day plan ABBA a date spent reading
praying and attending to domestic
matters and a day that didn't go so well
for Neely she was making her way to the
Atlantic coast as part of the slave
couple the two women a member of the
Mojave and an enslaved woman reveal the
solution between South Africa visual
subject as the model of taste and
requirement and the suffering and social
death of the enslaved the fragmented
narrative of Neely also reveals the
difficulty of not a possibility of
deploying an archival pragma a
description of a captive taken from
Mungo Park Journal to narrate a counter
history of modernity as becomes he
writes the park had not written about
her she would have been one of the many
anonymously women who died in the long
journey from the
to the West Africa suppose this is
precisely the challenge of DuPont his
project how does one provide a
description of what has been the
prevailing absence of an actor to his
presence in a displacement modernity and
delineate the contours of a black
counter aesthetic given the silence of
the archive the condi responds to this
challenge
in crafting a speculative narrative
enabled by if and would have been in
order to detail the manner in which
Neely enters the scene of modern culture
and the discourse of freedom she enters
through their desire for death it is in
the context of imagining Neely story
that we are first introduced to akagi's
allegory of reading which she describes
as a contrapuntal reading of the
distinctive that ultimately connected
lives of two subjects of modernity
located at opposite spectrums thus
ensuring a dialectic between a visible
subjects of modernity and its invisible
actors this album Oracle murmurs reading
is both way of excavating impossible
stories need our public's Labor's
placing Neely on the threshold of
modernity and in staging an encounter
between this terrible past and our
present the book of the material object
and textual assemblage is key to
elaborating the temporal dimensions of
slavery and its afterlife and there are
a number of photographs and images which
are placed in the text but which are not
simply illustration photographs taken by
the author of the slave River and a
scene long saw in Ghana and the door of
no return at Cape Castle are in dialogue
with the tax the images are not only to
illustrate his entry into the slave
council or the ritual stripping of the
cap
a way to become a commodity that rather
seemed to suggest the past that weekend
we enter here memory is spatialized
along the lines of our students
remembering that is if you dare to
venture to the loo de mmoire then
Neeley might be waiting for your
threshold and that standing at the door
the modern forms unleashed by slavery
are as palpable now as they were in the
18th century the subjunctive enables de
Conti to imagine the unimaginable and to
make approximate the beautiful and the
terrible the English lady and bear life
as nearly makes her way into the culture
of taste as a captive of modernity so to
delete visually encounter the stages of
dispossession and commodification this
is an incredibly interesting aspect of
the book for me because I think when I
was reading it I but okay it's a
scholarly study of 18th century culture
but there was something about the
placement of the images that made me
feel this is also a memorial text to for
here the book is as much a travellers
guide and the speculative narrative that
catapult is back to a past that number
volunteered to reenter acts of manure
and memorial tax and trying the others
live specifically the loss of her life
and marks and money meant Eliza's of
spaces and science of those denied even
the privilege of ruins again on page 84
she describes her entry into the castle
and on the page that accompanies the
text we have a full page reproduction of
the door of no return so I think I'm
going to cut the rest of my comments it
just actually raises a few questions in
one of the questions I'd actually like
to raise is about thinking about the
space of creolization there's a way that
an accounting for Africans performance
practices become the animates the point
that
had to negotiate laws and to remake
their identities in the context of these
stellar spaces and that what was created
with this kind of fashion culture and I
wonder how the tension between the
culture of taste and in slave culture
might be transformed if we also think
about the remaking of Europe and the
context that that encountered - and we
think of European culture as a culture
that's also realized and not simply
British and longer so you Connolly also
consider slave performance in the
counter culture or counter aesthetic to
the culture of tape and here I would ask
him and us to think about practices that
are indifferent or recalcitrant in
regard to the culture of taste
meaning cultural practices that are not
focused on parody satire fatigue another
question is how might terror itself be
formative of the aesthetic there's a
discussion of the sublime in European
painting or the aesthetic as a category
that disavows the terror of enslavement
but what happens if we just simply think
about the role terror as constitutive of
notions of the vehicle itself and I was
thinking about that particularly in
regard to slave culture and how my
thinking along these lines actually
trouble on the framework of sorrow and
pleasure and I guess there are few other
questions but one concerns the fragment
of the
book and I guess I think of you know if
you kinda it's being involved in a pen
Union project at least the allegory of
reading and the attention to the
fragment is definitely a part of that
and I guess I would raise the question
about fragment melancholia and the telus
of the project in terms of the
concluding fragments of the book and I
guess I wonder does redemption from
melancholia and the and the last
fragment of the book seems to suggest or
hold open the possibility of a different
kind of modernity one no longer haunted
by the ghosts of slavery is this an
intent an intended redemptive tell us or
a moment of excess and wild imaginings
made possible in 2009 and put no longer
so
thank you very much
okay absolutely be a very exciting
discussion and I want to begin by
thanking my different Mamadou for asking
me to respond to this brilliant book and
to all the staff a little bit in Christ
who have helped me put pictures on the
oil and other things and this is it was
far from the first time many of us have
joined together to discuss the Atlantic
world its interconnectedness and its
destabilizing contradictions this might
look on the surface I can you supposed
idly conversation with Columbia and
Carnegie Princeton but I always have
below the surface of representations
right to seek out the office stage
secrets work together to form the
incident studies initiative when mama
dewa 1927 questions of morality and
sexuality and silent generously
contributed a number of guest lectures
and without her permission I became both
natural
in this coporate of course apart
connections while teaching another
michigan atlanta cysts so i am really
looking forward to our conversation this
evening
of course also note that none of us are
actually from michigan appearances as
simon tells us can be deceiving
now Simon introduces his examination
from the interdependence of the granted
slavery and early and enlightenment than
the environment culture of taste with a
few lines from derek walcott the see is
history where are you - the battles your
martyrs and our state presumably white
boys asked where is your tribal memory
serves the apparently presumably black
boys responds in that gray malt the see
this epigraph brings to mind a powerful
transformative scene in August Wilson's
gem of the ocean in which a young black
man at sea within the violent gin from
Pittsburgh in the late 19th century by
two attention and political purpose when
he descends into the City of Bones that
lies beneath the ocean there were
private Horry of all who died in the
Middle Passage
terrified at first he m58 from Mahara
and with connectedness with - suffering
that he climbs there
emerging a brave new man in wall touch
poem as in Wilson's play the great logic
appears as an ocean of Bloody Mary
more equipped for which those thing
works to trouble its survivors black and
white assignment in slavery and the
culture case focuses on a different
aspect from the Atlantic seeing it less
is a repository of memories than as a
great theatrical stage where modern
subjectivity black and white of
choreographed and performed to principle
subjectivity Spelman companies stage
that the environment and of taste and
civilization and cultivation that of the
attributes way we use the rights of
subjects living taste so the cultivator
of blessed wealth and sensual pleasures
intimately linked psychologically and
ideologically unable to exist in
isolation from one another they appear
as the dangerous levels of modernity
simultaneously dependent in front and
destabilizing each other's authenticity
and legitimacy to understand the
wonderment must study the other his
economic and cultural environments his
fears and anxieties is desires and
determination the cultured case silent
insists became possible only because of
the commercial and consumer revolutions
have formed and informed enlightenment
Europe
and those revolutions in their turn
appeal brother Clayton African bodies
and then plantation slave economies that
trade made possible the culture of take
emerged out of the Atlantic along with
new understandings of freedom rights and
beauty all assume in their own meanings
only when contrasted to the debasement
and new strains of slavery in short
blackness colored the Atlantic world
washing against destabilizing Europe's
white landscape to see all this one must
look at the Atlantic
the vantage point of the spout for the
perspective of the peoples who violently
displaced from Africa produced the goods
the culture of taste and requirement
needed to properly display your
superiority it is to insist on the
interdependence II the inseparability of
misleading the enslaved enlightenment
liberalism and racial bondage social
polish and racialized violence it is to
recognize the centrality of Africa not
only to the Bolivian but to Europe and
the British Isles recognize the slide
slave huts that nestled in the shadow of
Augustan manor houses it is to assume
what performance theorists and theater
historian Joseph broach call space
circum atlantic vision of the emergence
of modernity
LaRouche a certain Atlantic perspective
focuses on the traces of the Atlantic
Holocaust in which he means the
diasporic and genocide in history of
Africa and the Americas and the ways
they have implanted they are impacted
and the honor of performances of our
cultural identities the ways the
stunningly beautiful costumes of the
modern by Indians
we've the richness of an indigenous
culture of 17th century
Deanna and the cultural connections
between native and African Americans
into 21st century performances or the
way New Orleans City Council built the
Superdome designed for the commercial
employ listed display a black athletic
bodies and later the containment of
black bodies during the harvest of
Katrina on the very site Lee Wallace
slave market had been located and so the
request cars are forecast consistently
color the performances of our modernity
well a great deal of the unspeakable
violence instrumental to the creation of
modernity mayor has officially forgotten
Joseph's coach insists certainly led to
memory and performance
he changed its consequences one of which
is that the unspeakable cannot be
landing forever in his principle
insulated in the culture of a silent
gives voice to the unspeakable
connections between slavery modernity
and the culture of taste
thus echoing ruptured circle Atlantic
vision a vision I would argue that is
central to Atlantic studies perspective
and here comes my first question for
Simon he tells us that he wants to to
audiences in particular students at the
culture of Chase students of diasporic
culture is he distancing his book from
Atlantic studies and if so what are his
criticisms of Atlantic studies certainly
Simon expand significantly of hundred
roaches vision of the ways cast are as
trouble performances of
it is not enough Simon insist to
discover traces of slavery in the
production of modernity we must go
further map the centrality of slaves and
slavery to the epistemology of the
Enlightenment plus later his role in the
process is probably to modern systems of
knowing and have seen oneself especially
to the form how the summoned post
mapping slavery centrality to the long
18th centuries world of tasteful
elegance and self-restraint along with
slave is destabilizing implications for
that culture through and the logical and
allegorical analysis Simon tells us and
most especially by exploring and I
thought the rhetoric of representation
and its business the semiotic hose
rather than concerning himself with the
authenticity of the experiences these
representations suggest for instance is
mother what about Simon turns to the
rhetoric of presentation to as he says
open the way for counterpoint a weaving
of the distinctive yet ultimately
connected facets of Atlantic modernity
so armed he fries 18th century culture
livid with anxieties and uncertainties
multiple revolutions flexed through it
fracturing old ways suggesting futures
both tempting and terrifying the
commercial fiscal and consumer
revolutions who instructed restructured
Britain's economy and class structure
the cultural supremacy of aristocratic
established prevalent before the power
of merchants and
she was to determine the pace of fashion
and taste serigraph is revolution
accompanied economics change economic
change leading to the depopulation of
America with Africans and Europeans
political revolutions followed the road
in empires giving birth to modern
Republic's and keeping pace with all
this assignment so painstakingly and
elegantly demonstrates aesthetic and
epistemological revolutions transform
concepts of Union and the production of
knowledge change became the one constant
new men new ways new ideologies gestured
towards the unknowable identity order
itself never seeing the illusionary
stability in this world Simon tells us
dependent on the determined construction
of a series of highly problematic binary
opposition's that juxtaposed the culture
of taste to the vulgarity of Commerce
Beauty to violence disability to
savagery reason to influence moderation
to passion liberty to bondage to the
metrical to the color the disdain to
fear behind each of these binaries lurk
the shadow of the slave and the reality
of white dependence on what was most
feared the savagery the ugliness of
slavers salmon brilliantly shows how
these diagonal decisions collapsed
unable to contain the power of the
infest
bangies desire to richly virtually
separate high and low beautiful and
we work in larger metropolitan colony
where we eat idli troubled and slaves
and former Britain and Americans covered
every Washington fashion headquarters or
although African or Mosley and to the
public prints then making a critiquing
plant culture the desire for cultural
purity Sangha process was continuous
haunted by what excluding or repressed
the Japanese that most captivated my
attention weather-wise that age of
silence telling analysis of colonial
culture and especially when I feel what
it divided and anxiety with the subject
of us boy and the Americas determinately
identifying as British a problematic
include status as silent points out a
totally promised telling phrase not
quite not quite living or borderline
black leggings white meals reduce the
comfortable sisters of different around
which enlightenment order was organized
we all practice assignment explains were
tainted not only by their distance from
the metropolis but by their connection
to work southern planters said we were
through thirds diary crews work
intimately were intimately involved in
the dirty work of running a plantation
supervising the planting out to made our
tobacco ceilings the manuring of fields
and the disappear disciplining of slaves
it is here that we find the absolute
intractable obstacle to the Creole claim
to admittance into the Finnish culture
of taste his connection to slavery
rather than is perfect he underscored
the culture of taste dependency
silent analysis of the portrait of Henry
Darnell Darnell the third demonstrates
is the small personal section there
demonstrate sensibility leading of the
rhetoric of representation and
portraiture as it underscores the
irrepressible ties binding the culture
taste to the culture of slavery of
course it is the slave boy that captured
silence attention well more to the point
the question why this length way is
positioned within the court that quarter
designed to establish the Darnell
family's claim to British gentility and
social polish the presence of the site
point the only problem that tries these
claims especially in the portrait of a
pedo gentlemen especially in the court
rhetoric real gentlemen for mr. Peck
quits may get away with it has assigned
merely of ostentatious and herbalism
expenditure but it pointed to more in
the colonies positioned in a slave
colony good so it was presence gestures
to this leg cuts and enslaved field
hands
what deliberately excluded to the
portrait as suggesting the dangerous
dependence of taste on slavery the slave
boys presence I can explain underscores
the devil buying the white Creole who
would be a gentleman taste his wealth
his superiority to Touro white satin
America's depended on the productivity
of an expensive slave and of course the
Creole gentleman has displayed these
legs Albia the most capable way as a
well-dressed servant tending his master
after day hunting the dead bear he holds
and I put I'm so blind I admittedly was
into this painting at the different but
dirty holes even fight that legend
fashionable activity the hunt seemed
less the slave boy harmonizes with the
portraits elegant backdrop the elaborate
balustrade the aristocratic gardens in
classical architecture that stretched to
the horizon or was illusionary since
they could be found nowhere in early a
consent to Maryland but this way
positioned at the shadowy Washington
portrait points in two directions to the
fantasized elegance within the portrait
back to the heart as the ugliness of
slavery out these are the very ugly
these are the very ugliness the very
horrors that impede the Creole
gentleman's efforts to be included
within the British world of taste and
gentle pleasures it is at this junction
at this point where the erotic black
body marks the absence of plantation
labor within the friendless picture but
also cause attention to the
transcendental presence as what enables
the dreams of the Masters Simon argues
in calendar it is at this intersection
that violence becomes essential
counterpoint to the work of art but a
tour de force of analysis there is what
part of the picture
however it's Simon is
comment upon the error the younger they
are clutches in his hands the law of the
bow that rests at his feet and the
quiver filled with arrows at his side
clearly these accouterments are intended
to confirm Darnell as the aristocratic
that you've just returned from the hunt
but by 18th cent by the 18th century
especially America's intentions
associated with the Americas the bow and
arrow invariably signals the Native
American and in this case even was
significantly his access to bigots I
needed to establish the white man
bribery I was legitimacy the slave as
the emblem of material riches and the
dashing Native American was these
actions summons the white Cleo's
domination of the american continent
that the arrow is also a phallic sign
one is tempted to say a floating
signifier as a pair the layer of meaning
to this portrait
but what I'd like to do is to point to a
second what struck me very good what
struck me and this was the the jewel
case that is suspended above what is
undoubtedly her genitalia is Michelle
which in the a71 agency he was a symbol
of sexuality and it is filled with
pearls I reminded me of Doris directed
right Dora when he talks of the jewel
case Mikasa as the emblem of doors
sexuality and if this if we can work
with that inter
occasion I thought this was an
interesting portrait because it's really
identifying the duchess of portsmouth
who started tells us because the oil is
iran 20 th century passive acceptance in
2000 another case that she is the
mistress of the kingdom tell us a second
and so it's essentially pointing the
viewers attention to her purchase
ability as a sexual object and then i
was struck by the the black snake or
servant in this in this picture and
assignment tells us that he's a boy and
I dumped out that and I don't think it's
too disturbing but I'm struck by the
similarity between the two figures
clothing the lace of the bodice of both
the lace of the sleeves the pearls on
the slaves neck the pearls suspended
over the Duchess's genitalia and I'm
thinking is this a portrait that is
saying both of these figures are in fact
sexual objects up for sale and therefore
as Simon's house shows us time and again
rapidly tying together the culture of
taste as represented by the Q's mistress
and the slave girl or boy themselves who
have
they'd already been purchased and
thinking of that in thinking the phallic
arrow
I was thinking can we think of these two
portraits as in conversation with one
another thing that Harry Darnell the
third and the the duchess of portsmouth
and as these two portraits talking to
each other across derek walcott great
mantid fault
and therefore problematizing the
difference between the world of the
colony in the world so that just wanted
my thoughts now if I can try to make
sense oh yeah I also had a question
our second question is a sign up page I
think I managed that but my questions my
second question for Simon he has a sword
to capture from my perspective anyway
the anxieties of the contradictions
central to the long edge of the century
of construction in part no guarantee by
analyzing the Sirians of the binaries
that we talked about slavery but he has
not placed the negative component of
these binaries in conversation with one
another
take for instance the connection between
women for and one of the name
of these wineries commerce Quiros slaves
would a a triangulation of the very
negative figures in these diets tell us
even more about the power of both
powered negativity and subject formation
and also give us a better sense of the
anxieties and contradictions Simon has
of sensitively been discussing and
analyzing so I'm wondering in that one
could play more with that and they could
even get war the anxieties and the
instability difference I'd like to move
to something which is not in sizings
book but which I something I would want
to know which i think is a parallel to
the kinds of things that Simon has been
working on and it seems to be the
difference
problem right sameness lies at the heart
of Simon's analysis and indeed of the
Lord saturation studies Simon focuses
his analysis on the culture of taste on
the scenarios and estrus technology if
we shift our eyes to another of the long
many personas the age of revolution we
will find similar anxiety with
intentions threatening again the product
matter structure of defense and sadness
which is we're thinking of politics of
within to the freedom of we're thinking
slavery this is against the N and the
limitations and the critiques of
liberalism that would have its around
these issues of difference and sameness
the edging that we structured political
and social order around rigid systems
and past gender and racial difference
but as the Age of Enlightenment walked
in to be a revolution these systems were
increasingly challenged Thomas Jefferson
declares old men who had an equal and
endowed with unalienable rights
Tom Paine celebrates the rights of men
the slaves and spent the men proclaimed
themselves free the French National
Assembly abolishes slavery as well as
Empire what are these moments which I
rotate between the fall of the Bastille
and Napoleon England radicals entertain
they even contemplated exploring
liberalism's promise of equality to the
world by the opening their theater of
the ages of the 19th
this vision had begun to play as one of
its earliest settlers Jefferson batter
to protect the institution of slavery in
the United States class and gender
distinctions were reinforced and
counter-revolution swept Europe and
because we all know that I think is very
telling
Keeks of liberalism 19th century
liberalism now in my remaining that is
that one would weekly at this moment of
possibility
when sameness is being proclaimed to get
difference and the ways the anxieties
the anxieties of challenging difference
and insisting on Satanist swamped this
moment and I will try to suggest the
parallels I see therefore between
assignments vision or analysis of
sameness empty and connection to be
pressed within the field of culture and
the containment of the radical
universalism seeding the promise by
enlightenment momentarily by in
liberalism Branigan and Irish gray or
the slave trade implantation of Lucia
who inspired the white text remain
embrace a radical vision of the rights
of all men and the horrors of slavery
moving to the United States right and
became an ardent member of the political
coalition Thomas Jefferson at home
between the southern fantasy and
northern economic
this segment of african-americans
dominates these pages african-americans
love Liberty with the same intensity is
what America we said in French to their
families the same passion or it's their
sameness the climate it feels not the
difference having long been oppressed by
God's northern inside southern Americans
would have given their freedom
gonnigan pointedly asked time and again
would they not strike down their
oppresses just as white Americans had
done when fighting British excitement
during
revolution can white American family
brush and explore an enemy so like
themselves house their cities and
countryside African Americans one Street
must be deported from the pure white us
and assembled in the back in the black
Republic situated at the farthest
reaches of the Louisiana Purchase
now here we try one of the first
examples of a policy of sectors of equal
a two-state solution and United States
located on the same continent but it's a
perfect solution one might think
especially as magnets and Brian's
imagination the new black American state
would receive sufficient financial and
technical support from the white
American state to establish an idea of a
public small family farms again parallel
in Jefferson vision of the illness
paradise but geographic separation is
rarely enough to quiet the anxieties
Branigan fold if the ocean cried in
grace of penguins around
having laid out his two-state solution
rhadigan spends the rest of his book
detailing the horrors that lay at the
heart of his colonization proposal the
horrors of miscegenation black men
desire and frequently seduce white women
into marryin their most especially what
this violation of the purity of a white
American Legion ravaging swords and
refuse to the Torah domestic years must
be prevented the argument purity and
impurity parallel silence invocation of
Mary Douglass's purity and danger is
this why we have no concept of the
mulatto in us murderers in Atlanta
ostensibly committed to the Equality the
sameness of all is there a lot of that
embodiment and racial fusions and thus
the quintet meant essentially Musil of
difference to destabilize you truly a
figure to claim the legitimate place
within the fused individual of us choose
in this country and identity
bringing me to this nationally I
apologize my coach's voice I'm getting
over laryngitis of everything I'll try
to be short which we can afford to do
which is my colleagues have already said
so much so many things that I
so first taking the manager Amanda
that mama dude gave us a few things
about what I see is this project main
contributions to the interpenetrating
who often vigorously isolationist field
over the 18th century studies colonial
studies Atlantic study and then at the
end I'll raise a few questions for her
discussion some of which have come up
already so obviously colonial questions
can no longer be considered a
marginalized subfield of 18th century
studies nor the last colonial history
and the cultural productions associated
with it I've often been approached in a
very compact meant alized way some
issues get a lot of attention summer
sees very little attention in my own
field was you know French and
francophone colonial history and
literature there's been a great deal of
attention devoted to the Haitian
Revolution for example and now we
aftermath the Haitian Revolution to the
point that prominent historian of that
period told me recently that he felt
felt that the field had become saturated
which has shocked me a little bit but I
I think that nonetheless in spite of
this kind of focus we don't have a very
good integrated sense of the questions
that Simon raises in his book on to what
I see as that question I think if we
generalizing a little bit I think if we
think about the field of literary
studies Empire has been a bigger
category than slavery and this is for
this is for a number of reasons the the
archive of cultural production
or supplemental text turns out not to be
very rich certainly extremely poor in
the French contacts a little richer in
the British context but not as rich as
one might suspect for the study of
slavery of course reading these texts
does not give you access to the agency
of the enslaved and so to some extent
the question of slavery has been
delegated by literary scholars to
historians and it's certainly time for a
repression of methodologies I think I
think the one scholars of cultural
productions literature art history
raised the question of slavery in its
place and culture the tendency has been
to read in a way that I would
characterize as positivistic that is to
say you know we take a narrative
fictional narrative or a travel
narrative it's a representation of
slavery the enslaved and the question
that is asked is well how does the
author position him or herself in
relation to the character or to the
institution of slavery and my feeling
has been that this this procedures kind
of positivistic procedure assumes that
we understand the relation in which the
text stands to the institution of
slavery and I think that's quite far
from being the case and before we get to
those kinds of analysis we need to ask
much larger framing questions about the
overall economy of slavery in relation
to to other cultural fields so I think
that the question is then how does how
does slavery fit into eighteenth-century
culture and how and I think Simon
certainly answer
ask this question to key dimensions of
what we think of as enlightenment
culture fit into Atlantic history this
is the process that you can look at both
ways especially locating and situating
from very wood perspective one of the
important undertakings of the book gives
them to raise this big-picture question
of how we might begin to situate slavery
in our interpretations of 18th century
British European society so Colonial
slavery as he shows was economically
tremendously important and in some
respects socially transformative it
represented a crucial dimension of the
periods dynamic culture production and
consumption colonial wealth we've
invested in the establishment of key
cultural institutions speak about the
foundation of all souls College and the
contributions of corrington
colonial planters yet this this material
centrality this investment is not always
evident in the cultural productions of
the period and particularly in the
leading discourses that we associate
with the Enlightenment so the problem
that Simon I think definitely addresses
is how to think presence in relationship
silence in an absence how to think
slavery as a dimension of social
experience and cultural experience that
was marginalized without being marginal
this is a complicated question how to
integrate colonial and metropolitan
histories
without erasing the boundaries and the
separations that kept them apart in the
18th century and that have continued to
keep them apart in historical and
critical discourses and so he approaches
this this set of questions or this this
paradoxes is problematic through the
very extensive network of 18th century
European discs
that deal with questions of taste
cultural refinement and aesthetic
experience and as he explains him and my
colleagues had already gone oh goodness
this is a fertile terrain it's really an
essential terrain is the key ground for
this question because 17th and 18th
century philosophers tried to reconcile
commerce and consumption as the material
supports of sensory pleasure with modes
of experience that were often presumed
to be transcendent so the aesthetic
sensation as a transcendent experience
has to be reconciled with materiality is
inflation and with commerce and
consumption this operation of
reconciliation was aligned with the
shifting boundaries of class identity
the breakdown of the rigid distinction
between aristocratic and bourgeois
Sensibility
by the 18th century the links between
taste and elegance consumption and
commerce were becoming impossible to
overlook and so philosophers had to
adjust their theoretical models you can
no longer assume that the aristocracy
didn't have money it was a paragon of
taste and this medical payment but if
the proximity of tasty corners brings
the question of slavery to the fore the
seminal thinkers of the Enlightenment
did not always speak directly or
extensively about slavery and so I think
and this is a very important dimension
of the dead of the book rather than
focusing on how Locke Hume under Smith
can't reconciled morality aesthetics and
slavery it can be gestures to loose
intersections among different discourses
different societal levels different
geographies and I and I want to confess
here that initially when I was in those
reading and sadya spoke about it
question of the fragment was a little
frustrated and I wanted you to press
home the argument I wanted to know where
you came down on luck and slavery in
poverty in that debate and then I know I
thought about it and I realized that the
fragment is of strategy and that there
is this kind of paratactic spelling on
the strategy of juxtaposition this
staging of encounters would even say
missed encounters in the psychoanalytic
sense where a missed encounter is also a
particular kind of part of an encounter
so we started reading of luck and then
suddenly it's broken after we're in the
planter and Columbia Advocate Edward
Long's
meditations on on slavery and I think
that that disruptive effect of the
pragmatism is crucial it's it's part of
an allegory of beggar minion allegory of
reading as sadya eloquently explained
it's also I think an important fruitful
strategy in Atlantic history where
things are not relations are not always
evident sometimes there are a reason
separation that need to be reconstructed
I think this is is an important
technique it's very present in the
iconography of the book which is rich
and wonderful and I fully agree with
what has already been said about the
presentation of visual images often
pairings parallels that are not parallel
we find illustrations designs for
Palladian architecture in British
mansions just opposed with a mirror
console or with mansions in Barbados or
Jamaica for example these these near
Carlos these near misses disrupt the
unified meaning of the
which decontextualize it and put it in
circulation put it into a wider Atlantic
framework there's also a kind of
haunting effect one image is haunted by
the other and ideas book about how some
of the photographs are your own it
introduces a dimension of the present
your personal journey I think it's kind
of like a haunting in Reverse you know
that the present disrupting this vision
of the Palladian mansion
so the book proposes and I feel great
till the finish you at this argument
that in order to reconcile the
centrality of slavery to many aspects of
British 18th century society with its
relatively peripheral status in art and
culture we must bring into play a kind
of loosely psychoanalytic apparatus of
trauma refreshen disavowal in my own
work I talk about economies of
displacement the relationship between
colonial field and the oriental for
example I would read about Dracula and
instance of that kind of displacement
which transfer from the standpoint of
Atlantic cultural history
I am I very much the Corre into the
question of how taste and aesthetic
refinements were appropriated as
necessary qualities that new newly
minted American identity by figures such
as Thomas Jefferson and Guggenheim
Warren
so in this environment where there was
no geographic separation between slavery
and aesthetic judgment San Manuel de
Conde argues that reconciliation
operated less in the mode of repression
disavowal and and was through a
mechanism of what he calls duplicity and
and here Carolyn set this up wonderfully
by speaking about the contrast between
the kind of British portraiture in which
a shadowy black figure reflects power
reflects global power opulence
contrasting you know a presumed idea
Beauty sensuality eroticism and a
colonial portrait in which those things
are also in play that power is inscribed
much more directly the page or the black
figure in the portrait of Darnell wears
a collar at much Kaneda palace we would
say in French so subjection is figured
in a different manner in those paintings
but it is it is to Placitas because
nonetheless the images aestheticized
this is not you know slavery in its most
barbaric dimensions and see that that
the slaves well-dressed seems to be you
know adoring of their master and so
forth so a number of questions and
issues that thanks for adding again some
of the more usual about so one one
aspect that I thought was a little bit
absent perhaps that this is a little bit
my own obsession from the discussion of
statuses and taste and pleasure with the
category of the commodity as a crucial
intermediary between colonial and
metropolitan environments so a lot of
the pleasure taken in consumer goods in
in 18th century Europe concerned the
products of colonial agribusiness you
discuss coffee houses a great deal of
spheres of sociability but I was
thinking also about coffee that's only
served errand and its geography coffee
sugar chocolate but also expanding
further sectors such as textiles and
furniture where colonial imports played
a very important role both in in
launching industrial mass production and
in generating currency fashion five
lashes its mediates between mass
production and
the question of commodities connects to
the question of the present which
setting aside the photographs attending
are really really wonderful
I am wondering about how how you bring
this into the context of contemporary
let's say globalization for shorthand so
eighteenth century writers thinkers
reconciled the barbers miss Lavery with
herself perception of their refinement
as subjects we confronted different that
not entirely unrelated set of questions
about the ethics of offshore productions
it's very much you know of the moment
now in relation to the question of Apple
plants in China for example this this
question of offshore production its
ethics consumption and production
elsewhere in circumstances that we know
to be bad and yet we know them on a
certain level because with unthought to
know one might think another thing you
emphasize Englishness to love and they
know that this has been a major area of
the cultivation and English identity is
refined humane irrational and so forth
and you speak about the difficulties
experienced by the the the air of this
Creole fortune bad-boy William Beckford
homosexual misfit you know in his
attempt to launder colonial money
through his aesthetic pursuits as their
collector and a builder patron of the
Arts I'm just wondering how English that
could really wanted to be you know to
what extent Englishness was a real
really of value for him I mean he wrote
the Vatican French he spent a lot of
time in Paris it's you know it's this
oriental tale grounded in he
like but there's something else I think
was going on there that isn't just
foolishness but I don't want to just
talk about the marginalization of French
certainly would be a hobby horse but I'm
thinking rather about the Atlantic books
perspective and how bringing French into
a you know the francophone world into a
dialogue with Britain does give us a
kind of circa magic geography which I
wrote also constructs one degree in his
in his work I thought about this a
little bit in my book in in the context
of furniture and how we see the same
furniture fashions on the west coast of
France the mud in Paris as in Britain
and in the colony Vasilis there's a kind
of continuity of commodity and and style
taste fashion there that one could speak
about if if we are willing to go beyond
these National Academies these national
categories have an important role but
they're not they could be reading and
finding though I myself for completely
guilty of staying within those
boundaries the second part and lastly my
last thing concerns the way you use the
the concept of modernity so at certain
moments not everyone about that
occasionally I thought that the concept
was a little bit rarefied and that you
discuss the emotions of a theory if not
an experience of free autonomous
subjects personhood in enlightenment
moral and political sort it seems to me
in a way that the thought was being
distilled and projected back onto the
entirety of the period so that we we buy
into our own myth of the Enlightenment
of modernity in a way I think that if
all eighteenth-century subjects you know
really thought of themselves as free
autonomous persons in Europe then
slavery would be even harder to explain
great deal harder to explain but that
was not the case and they were even you
know I know in France and many points in
the 18th century people called for the
establishment of slavery in France
because it might be better for the
working for which is obviously based on
complete ignorance of the conditions of
slavery but nonetheless the 18th century
was very heterogeneous in times
experience and in terms of its literary
culture and our categories are the
enlightenment of modernity a little bit
of an abstraction from that
heterogeneity
I think this lines up a little bit of
what you were saying about the age
revolution in the sense that we have to
understand the Haitian Revolution as
being internally very heterogeneous and
that is about the pursuit of an
Enlightenment it's a deal in a very
clear-cut sense that's part of it but
there are other dimensions too and that
helps us to understand a little bit the
American Revolution the Haitian
Revolution and thereafter a gift I wish
I wish of devising a book after all
these comments because it's just
wonderful and they wonderful comment
because they seem to not wanna engage
with a book in very substantive ways but
also to recognize the anxieties and
desires of my driving it's a book that
was very difficult to write not so much
because of its manifest subjects but
losing flavor is difficult face about
but actually it was much more difficult
because of methodological issues raised
so since I don't know 20 minutes
I'm not going to kind of rehearse what I
was trying to do because I didn't
present a wonderful situation of that
what I'd like to do is that
another question very important not all
of course I've got some of them
especially those have to do with the
deposition methods and my own
imagination of where I wanted this one
to go and we have to tell a bit short
let me start with the question of the
little process of creolization because
Oh towards the end of the book it if you
could obvious to me that in this
encounter between masters and slaves as
many other people as noted before
something new had emerged some kind of
subject some kind of casual experience
some kind of way of being in a world
which was enabled by these moments of
violence and in many cases of time and
contrast were difficult so I spend a lot
of time talking about the creolization
of the African in the new world but the
idea is right to note that it would have
been interesting to think about the
criminalization yeah the European
Creoles I deal with these problematic
figures who emerged in the colonial
world for battle as well and so on but
let me interesting to think about what
European society looks like after
enslavement because something is
happening there literally in terms the
appropriation of say cultures influences
and so on but because it seems to mean
that this is very haunting becomes it
wasn't it was impossible to imagine all
these categories of subjectivity of
freedom of even everyday life given the
destabilization enslavement so in a
sense why I fought enslavement was
Bishop understanding mortality
immortality's is that on one hand it
destabilizes it but precisely because it
stabilizes that we need to develop these
Asafa core and other categories to stay
so there's a way in which civilization
that large project of enlightenment
which is a project of trying to theorize
and rationalize and provide us with ways
of explaining the world where see pages
are going to be contained was a
neighborhood where certain kind of
awareness of the power of the slave so
that were questions that's how many
aesthetic because they said it was
always incident desire of what
transcendental aesthetic was an attempt
to give us a world in which the
materiality of social life the politics
of it so we could be contained at the
second level but I'm saying the
existence of the second level transient
level was enabled almost what was kind
of desired decides because when I wear
nest of it instability of Labor so when
you talk about slavery being absent
there no slaves in France or in England
or Scotland it's precisely because of
our own awareness of the influence and
the power and I would say that awareness
that hauntings part of the creolization
or if we want to use another time the
provincial ization of Europe that that
what appear to be very stable European
centers always constantly defined by
this other field that I discussed
briefly the influence of the slave on
the law at that kind of ties to my place
last point about sense a global presence
pregnant because one of the questions I
was asked a few years ago was were
people in Britain on the web the coffee
houses while they actually over all that
sugar sweetened the coffee was produced
in this brutal regimen of labour have a
conscious of it and it's a question I
keep on thinking about
becoming clear as indicator of these
discussions about our iPads and iPhones
does that extend we are aware some
extent but you see a lot of where or
other we don't have been that awareness
to service so we all are aware of it I'm
talking about it but because we don't
want to be about these commodities the
essence in which possible to develop in
the system for recognizing the existence
of these categories for the same time
are we holding so that's part of the
realization that fact that we have to be
aware at a certain level but the symptom
have to repress that kind of awareness
so that the business of consuming
commodities continue so that's the way I
kind of see the problem of polarization
city also asked about slave performance
and especially those modes of
performance or aesthetic representation
which you are indifferent to the culture
of taste and the reason why this
question comes up has to be the fact
that I spend a lot of time talking about
the slaves of procreation and parenting
of the forms that they were seeing so
the question man is what exactly might
be happening that's indifferent to those
forms it's an important question not so
much because of an answer but because it
raises really the difficulties of
talking about slaves as compared to
subjects a vampire most of my field has
been quite attractive subject matter and
the reason for that difficulty
quite obvious is the existence of this
powerful archive that's going to talk
about the British in India British in
Africa the confirm that assuit archive
you may have half doubt that that's most
of representation of those centers but
there's a way in which you can kind of
produce narratives which are premised on
the presence of subjects whereas in the
case of slavery what you are strong what
stripes one is again this absence so
that even when when I was tempted to
think about modes of social reproduction
of
production that were indifferent to
cultural taste I was confronted by the
problem of actually having to recover
those accept as they have been
represented by the planters themselves
so one question we could ask ourselves
is again how do we go about talking
about forms of resistance which certain
extent are there but I'm presented to us
Antonius fragmented sometimes very
distorted forms I talked a bit about
obeah in Jamaica mirror and all these
forms of religious practices which seem
to hold up the possibility of
indifference but was other hand they
have already been appropriated that's
part of the texts of masters Ruiz
fascinated by the Gothic elements so the
Gothic element tends then to take away
from that which is indifferent this
indifferent nest by appropriating
undomesticated
so so again I'm not sure I want to do
that now kara raised an important
question of audience especially Atlantic
studies and I thought that my response
to that I have two responses why his
simple cough has to be the moment of
production book and it could be that I
was trying to dissociate myself from
Illinois so in that sense I was a bit
worried by the model of the Baraka
planting has directly below it precisely
because at that point you raised that
there are different colonies doing
different kinds of works and depending
on where you are the sheer history and
materiality of these moments does
complicate things so these are not
transactions which
simple as clear-cut as Eli suggested so
the simple trench has maybe was trying
to distance myself on that but perhaps a
much more useful response is to think
about the question not so much Atlantic
studies and in constitutive but our own
understanding of what the Atlantic is
given the fact that the Atlantic is a
metaphor it's a figure of encounter
between the most African coast the
Americas and so on but that's just one
kind of traffic one traffic cop traffic
I found very useful if the casual
traffic between the antebellum South
and Olivia when you think about the bay
those planters investing in the
Carolinas and kind of developing
different practices I thought you should
have a cultivation and so on that's one
way of thinking about the Atlantic is to
think about the Atlantic as always being
different linguistic zones but also how
we position our geography your position
and Caribbean in relation to the
antebellum South it's like a different
story when you position the Caribbean in
relation to the continent in South
America to swim up to them in a visual
story emerges because you begin to go
into they're not just British
experiences so thinking about how that
mark and continues to be built around
can also raises the question of the
power negativity design importance to my
project and I have previously entire
eight that once we have talked about all
these forms of negativity that exist the
transgender in terms of sexuality in
terms of region
and they are very important and one
could triangulate and try and break out
of the finally suppose welcome for me
the question is why why did I an
instrument finalist and why did I resist
the triangulation as the example of
Macbeth and Neely shows there is a way
which of course the binary was kind of
my way of trying to negotiate diverse
terrain but also I suspected that this
is the problem what do you do with by
now is we shall be put into operation so
that the system and and work how how how
do you and do those binaries without at
the same time displacing the work cannot
do it problems different said less
because there's a way in which the
system insists on binary oppositions
which might appear not that way to be as
profound as the system suggests but
those binary opposition's are important
because they show us a kind of self
representation of this there are ways in
which people want at least the
bourgeoisie needs binaries you know that
to negotiate this very complicated world
of the commodity of materiality and of
cultures would entail and the challenge
there for us journalists is how to
recognize the binaries let us suggest
originally to connect automatically
they're not working and perhaps I could
have I could have gone much more into
that there were sections which
eventually didn't get into the book
where I was interested especially of
course not so much a deal but question
to situate the status of beauty also
connected
sexual attention transition of certainty
no.2 another way they are ways in which
questions of beauty while predicated on
all sorts of type of us rules of my
ugliness and expect that's something we
talked about going to mad lines
questions of things more important the
problem of the slave as an agent
obviously because when we talk about 20
subjects subjects of Empire the
subjectivity are not as as complicated
when you talk about the question of
agency is perhaps the most difficult
because you have a subject who is
defined and come on but talks back so
appears not as an agency and one of the
things I noticed that was fascinating to
me the archives is the doubts that
complicated nation of the slave raised
among the Masters is assuming that going
to buy a slave there's no difference
from buying a horse but the moment you
start attaching that means something
something different and so the question
of asking is what that does that mean
perception or the Masters perspective
obviously this in the end what happens
because my argument is that there's a
way in relation with that soft because
your vertical development of of the
slave of the commodity precisely because
this is not an angle and the sling is
not a horse but it's precisely because
the set is not the horse that we need to
develop these very elaborate theories of
showing why the slave is not an agent so
on so again is that a kind of definite
American is fascinated
but that final pointer I wanted to
respond to my tonight's point about
slavery forces asked adjust the
theoretical models slavery forces us to
be seeing the commodity and absolutely
right I could have talked much about
commodity and commodification and it
would have talked about other
commodities and possibly should have
talked about textiles furnishes but I
thought that one way of trying to
address your frustration when you're
talking about discussing Locke and then
I swing to Islam and then I swing back
to Hutchinson someone else points the
reason for that is absolutely
that's an illogical but it's also my own
sense that perhaps the best way of
dealing with categories is to recognize
their fragmented nature because the
fragment enables us to to contain or
hold on to the categories has already
broken down not as powerful as this
seems to be a kind of I was thinking
here Bota Benjamin I think in the
philosophy of history asking us to have
a weak messianic sense so I was thinking
that perhaps one way in which these
categories can be adjusted and be
deconstructed is for them to always be
seen as incomplete as weak because if we
do what we attempted to do which is to
pursue them so their logical basis and
conclusions then my fear was I might end
up in producing those categories within
the album mythologizing and so on so I
worried for example if I pursue the
category of sensibility or the category
of property and try and sort out its con
traditions to which a kind of logical
conclusion then what I might end up
doing is help the catabolic cleanse
itself of the materiality that I wanted
it continuously remember the source of
its aunty so in other words we're wrong
becomes very important is precisely
because most were writing about that but
long as you that Edward long thinking
about race belongs to the outpost of
empire it's so far out some Hyneman
noot english but i come to that argument
very powerfully by suggesting that
actually what long is saying about the
slave about the slave an identity and
sensibility and subjectivity is quite
important in authorizing the work of you
kind of all those people who never left
their hometowns but city of yarra is the
boundary and rascal character of the
slip is a way in which the evidence the
support to certain extent the very
dynastar around which the stinking
dispute around is coming from long and
the persistence of long and the
connections like Jefferson you can see a
whole set of ideas that are circulating
the idea that are circulating are those
ideas which are actually ideas issue we
should not be paying attention to
because we cannot least and closes
precisely because of a kind of
popularity of those ideas which cannot
withstand closest to him of course
they become important in informing
theorization of slaves as known subject
or subjects let me end with two points
one the question of Englishness that has
to do with my own formation intellectual
phone
and muttley is absolutely right to
suggest that the bank for in fact was
much more interested in the French the
Italian they have a European and he was
absolutely English but of course my
argument is this precisely because we
Stan was sent tell me tell us that each
identity that he becomes a collector of
European goods goods Victor so inept as
you could say that the collection of
French things the grand tourism so on
don't smoke him as an english treid mrk
he must after 20 century english that's
what you do Moustakas got France and you
buy stuff you go on trying to it and so
on I thought they actually that that's I
could have talked about it a little bit
more but it doesn't take away the point
for that when we focus on as French of
people like you and Chrisman have done
if we we focus on the Dutch and the idea
has interesting this was Dutch sometimes
focusing on the sweet and so on and we
need to see either how these questions
are connected but also disconnected they
are both European projects but they also
national projects because they become
European projects at the time when the
national project is also important but
with any class of 18th century it's the
age of nationalism in a sense the first
of the age of of Europe of a kind of
universal identity something we can talk
about kind of what I want to end with
the tell us the redemptive the book is
built around melancholia as critical
practice the book is driven by a certain
sense of loss and lack
not only my own but the objects of
analysis it's a book driven by a sense
of the gaps in history of silences of
absences and my own desire to tease them
out and speculate on what
apparently we could have listened to
these lost stories and so that sense of
loss does mean to change at the very end
in the last fragment which is the
fragment of 2009 which talked about a
kind of redemptive moment when the
ghosts of slavery exercised and that's
just where that is just a youth fall in
anger and it's also my own desire
perhaps to counter the melancholic with
a certain kind of utopian longing and
suggest that that's perhaps the reason
why I keep on going to the cingulum
alternative is precisely because of my
own attachment to the idea of freedom
and its possibility so so when I talk
about the Obama moment I talk about it
as a moment when when one walks away
from ghosts of the past and finds a
certain kind of fulfillment in this this
moment when slavery is no longer part of
the presence but of the past no it's
possible for slavery to be confined to a
past or a fair way in which actually
slavery is a condition of possibility of
modernity in which case one can hope
that the exercise that can't because in
the end and we look at the
infrastructure of maternity what we see
constantly she's not going away from it
and that's why of course is the great
example of the African burial ground
because both examples people coming up
in today and Veracruz Cape Town South
Africa dead faces of modern culture
built on the graves of slaves and so in
that sense perhaps we can't exercise but
if we don't exercise slavery and we talk
about the moment of freedom